a few Democrats are saying this is about
time something is done so let's see if
they keep that decision after they hear
that we agree with them the choices that
Twitter makes when it chooses to
suppress and it blacklist shadow band or
editorial decisions pure and simple
their editorial decisions in those
moments Twitter ceases to be a neutral
public platform and they become an
editor with a viewpoint and I think we
can say that about others also whether
you're looking at Google whether you're
looking at Facebook and perhaps others
one egregious example is when they try
to silence views they disagree with by
selectively applying a fact check fact
check
FAC T fact check what they choose to
fact check and what they choose to
ignore or even promote is nothing more
than a political activism group or
political activism and it's
inappropriate you look at what's
happened you look at where they're going
where they're coming from I think you
all see it yourselves this censorship
and bias is a threat to freedom itself
imagine if your phone company silenced
or edited your conversation social media
companies are vastly more power and more
reach than any phone company and the
United States more reach actually than
your newspapers by far more reach than a
lot of your traditional forms of
communication therefore today I'm
signing an executive order to protect
and uphold the free speech and rights of
the American people currently social
media giants like Twitter receive an
unprecedented liability shield based on
the theory that they're a neutral
platform which they are not not an
editor with a viewpoint my executive
order calls for new regulations under
Section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act to make it that social media
companies that engage in censoring or
any political conduct will not be able
to keep their liability shield that's a
big deal they have a shield they can do
what they want they have a she
they're not gonna have that shield my
executive order further instructs the
Federal Trade Commission FTC to prohibit
social media companies from engaging in
any deceptive acts or practices
affecting commerce this authority
resides in Section 5 of the Federal
Trade Commission Act I think you know it
pretty well
most of you know very well I would think
you know it quite well right
additionally I'm directing the Attorney
General to work cooperatively with the
states he's going to be working very
much and very closely in cooperation
with these states to enforce their own
laws against such deceptive business
practices the states have broad and
powerful authority to regulate in this
arena and they'll be doing it also and
we encourage them to do it if they see
exactly as we've been seeing it's what
they're doing is tantamount to
monopolies you can say it's tantamount
to taking over the airwaves
can't let it happen otherwise we're not
going to have a democracy we're not
going to have anything to do with a
republic finally I'm directing my
administration to develop policies and
procedures to ensure taxpayer dollars
are not going in any social media
company that repress free speech the
government spends billions of dollars on
giving them money they're rich enough so
we're going to be doing none of it or
very little of it as president I'll not
allow the American people to be bullied
by these giant corporations many people
have wanted this to be done by
presidents for a long time and now we're
doing it and I'm sure they'll be doing a
lawsuit and I'm also sure that we're
going to be going for legislation in
addition to this and the legislation
will start immediately and I tell you
I've been called by Democrats that want
to do this and so I think you could
possibly have a bipartisan situation but
we're fed up with it and it's unfair and
it's been very unfair and we'll see what
happens any questions
even they're concerned with Twitter have
you given any consideration to deleting
your accounts just walking away from
this platform you've been so critical of
well you know you weren't fake I would
not even think about I would do that in
a heartbeat but the news the news is
fake the if you look at what gets
printed in newspapers if only the public
could understand where you know they're
reading a story and they think it's real
and it's not real in so many cases and
I'm not saying in every case you have
some great journalists you have some
journalists that I have great respect
for but largely I find at least in a
political sense there's so much fake
news it's disgraceful I would do that in
a heartbeat if I had fair if we had a
fair press in this country I would do
that in a heartbeat there's nothing I'd
rather do than get rid of my whole
Twitter account but I'm able to get to I
guess a hundred and eighty-six million
people when you add up all the different
accounts and and Facebook and Instagram
it's a lot of people and that's more
than the media companies have frankly
buy a lot and so if I get a story that's
wrong I can put a social media I don't
usually use the word footer I use I say
social media but I put something out and
the next day or the next hour the next
minute everybody's reading about it so
I'm able to refute fake news and that's
very important I'd like to ask the
Attorney General please to say a couple
of words and he's very strongly behind
it
backing it very powerfully and again
we're going to be doing this we're also
going through Congress well as you
mentioned mr. president one of the
things that I found has the broadest
bipartisan support these days is the
feeling that this provision section 230
has been stretched way beyond its
original
and people feel that on both sides of
the aisle this was adopted 25 years ago
to protect the fledgling industry and
its purpose was to allow websites that
were serving as essentially bulletin
boards for diverse their farming content
coming on to say that you're not
responsible for the content of that
third-party information and it also
tried to encourage these companies to
take down things like child pornography
or human trafficking advertising and
things by saying if you act to remove
this kind of objectionable material you
won't you won't be liable for taking it
down now it's been completely stretched
to allow it have become really behemoths
who control a lot of the flow of
information in our society to engage in
censorship of that information and to
act as editors and and publishers of the
material so when they put on their own
content like fact-checked content onto
other people's content and when they
curate their collection and when they
start censoring a particular content
including in many cases of the direction
of fallen governments like Communist
China they become publishers and they
shouldn't be entitled the same kind of
shield that was set up earlier
now this executive order is a very
strong step toward addressing this
problem it sets up a rulemaking
procedure that will eventually be under
the FCC - to try to get back to the
original interpretation and
understanding of section 230 it also
empowers the Attorney General to work
with state attorneys general to come up
with model legislation that addresses
this at the state level and we're
preparing federal legislation which we
will be sending over shortly for review
the Office of Management and Budget so
this is an important step to get back to
the original understanding you know
there's a bit of a bait-and-switch
that's occurred in our society these
companies grew because they held
themselves out as public forums as free
public forums where variety of voices
and diverse voices could come on and be
heard that's how they grew that's how
they attracted the eyeballs that's why
people joined them but now that they
have become these very powerful networks
of eyeballs that they can roam by
holding themselves out as free public
forums they now switched and they were
using that market power to force
particular viewpoints and that's wrong
it has to be addressed not only to this
executive order but I think litigation
going forward but I think the further
action on Capitol Hill yes actually I do
of mr. Attorney General not only have
you been against section 230 and the
president has been against section 230
the vice president has said he's against
section 230 do you believe that the
executive order that the president is
about the sign in any way repeals or
amend section 230 no it doesn't repeal
the section 230 and I'm not against
section 230 if it was properly
interpreted interpreted and properly
applied but it's been stretched and I
don't know if anyone on Capitol Hill who
doesn't agree that it's been stretched
beyond its original attention I think
this will help me get back to the right
balance mr. general can you give us more
details on the legislation both you and
the president referred to what do you
want to do in that legislation well
we're still reviewing a number of
possibilities and that'd be premature
for me - this was made new bill it's
just you move forward totally change to
30 what I think we can say is we're
going to regulate it's a provision and
we're gonna regulate it you think a look
at this as an example
was just at Twitter moments for the
Muller witch-hunt so we won we were the
right you see what's happened to total
fraud it was a total fraud
seventy six to one okay seventy six to
one you look at it you think that's fair
Twitter classifies the term illegal
alien as hate speech illegal in but and
viciously you look at what China I mean
just article after article here's one
this is our this is the arbitrary this
guy is the operator of what's supposed
to go on Twitter he's the one he thought
that he thought and if you CNN as a
guide CNN which is fake news who used to
CNN as a guide his name is UL Roth and
he's the one that said that mail
invalidate you look mailing no fraud no
fraud really why did you take a look all
over the country this case is all over
the country if we went to mail-in ballot
our election all over the world would
look as a total joke it would be a total
joke there's such fraud and abuse and
you know about harvesting where they
harvest the ballots and they go and grab
them and they go to people's houses and
say sign here now doesn't work out now
an absentee ballot you can't be there or
you're sick and you go and you register
you do all sorts of things to get that
ballot and there's good security
measures but when they send out like in
California millions and millions of
balance to anybody that's breathing
anybody in California that's breathing
gets a ballot mr. president that's not
true
so here's your patient man and that's
our Twitter and the amazing thing is
he's wrong and even know no matter who
it is they will admit that his room
because there's tremendous controversy
on mail-in voting and I can say this the
Republican Party cannot let it happen
we know Gavin Newsom governor Ducey has
not sent ballots out to everybody in
California they're only going to
registered voters how many so how many
so so what your what your tweeting said
was was was not wrong I was not correct
it was wrong okay oh really
so when he sent you have 28 million
ballots and they're in all the mailboxes
and kids go and they raid the mailboxes
and they hand them to people that are
signing the ballots down the end of the
street which is happening they grab the
ballots you don't think that happens his
ballot harvesting we're all of us you
know we had seven elections for Congress
and they were like tied and they lost
every one of them because they came and
they dropped a whole pile of balance on
the table but you don't think they they
rip the matter mailboxes it's all the
time you read about it you can read
about it take a look there do worse than
that in some cases they won't sell them
like to a Republican community a
conservative community they don't happen
to send the balance to those communities
and there's no way of checking no you
have to go and you have to vote voting
is a great thing
voting we would be the laughingstock of
the world and if you just use common
sense you know that's gonna happen but
they raid the mailboxes they can even
print ballots they get the same paper
the same machine nothing special they
get the same paper the same machine they
print ballots and bill would have to do
a great job to catch them doing it or
your state authorities would have to but
you have tremendous potential and you
have tremendous for an abuse but you
have tremendous potential for fraud and
abuse go ahead mr. president you get
that in one of your Twitter
or one of your tweets that you would
consider shutting down Twitter and
social media companies did you actually
mean you'd want to shut down I think
maybe you know I tell you what I have so
much it seems influence over Twitter in
the sense of people wanting to seek out
Twitter because of what I have I have a
vast number with a number of platforms
as you know we have followed millions
and millions of people
I think this if Twitter were not
honorable if you're gonna have a guy
like this for your judge and jury I
think you shut it down as far as I'm
concerned but I'd have to go through a
legal process how would you set down I
don't know I'd have to ask the lawyers
I'd have to go through a legal process
if it were legal if we were able to be
legally shut down I would do it I think
I'd be hurting it very badly if we
didn't use it anymore I mean we have
other sites we could use I guess or
would have to develop other sides but
and I'm not just talking about Twitter
look at Facebook look at the tribunal
they set up at Facebook this woman who
you remember testifying recently in
Congress her hatred was so incredible to
what the Republican Party and me that
there is no way you can get a fair trial
so this is not like it's supposed to be
this is not like it's supposed to be so
we're gonna see what happens
and you know what I guess it's gonna be
challenged in court what is it but I
think will do very well as to potential
litigation can you discuss the timing of
that and what is the remedy that you're
going to be seeking no I what I was
referring to there there is litigation
going on all the time on on section 230
in its scope and we would look for
appropriate vehicles to weigh in file
statement of interest so you wouldn't be
filing an in dimensional cell
thank you I'm worried about the
situation on the border between India
and China India he loves India so much
she's never asked a question other than
an India question and that's okay I just
got back from India right
I just need Kovas back I know they like
being India I think they like me in
India certainly more than the media
likes me and I like Modi
I like your Prime Minister a lot even
great Jeremy yeah they have a big
conflict going with India and China is
that what you're talking about yes they
have a big conflict going with India and
China two countries with 1.4 billion
people two countries with very powerful
militaries and India's not happy and
probably China's not happy but I can
tell you I did speak to Prime Minister
Modi he's not he's not in a good mood
about what's going on with China have
you spoken to me finish what yesterday
you do did about do you want to mediate
between India and China on this issue I
wouldn't do that you know I would do
that if they if they thought it would
help if I were the mediator or the
arbiter I would do that so I'll say go
ahead have you spoken to the family of
George Floyd yet no I haven't but I feel
very very badly it's a very shocking
sight bill and I were talking about it
before it's one of the reasons Bill's
here right now because as you know we're
very much involved and I've asked the
Attorney General FBI and the Attorney
General to take a very strong look and
to see what went on because that was a
very very bad thing that I saw I saw it
last night and I didn't like it should
be prosecuted I'm not gonna make any
comment right now I can tell you I think
what I saw was not good was not good
very bad for anybody else are you
definitively staying in the us-china
trade deal we'll be announcing what
we're doing tomorrow with respect to
China and we are not happy with China we
are not happy with what's happened all
over the world people are suffering 186
countries
all over the world is suffering we're
not happy okay thank you very much let's
go come on thank you thank you thank you
everybody